[Music]  here are three easy ways you can fight  food waste your own home one is use the  whole vegetable things like using carrot  tops to make pesto or pickling a carrot  if it gets all the - we'll be using the  whole vegetable help you reduce food  waste number two thing you can do is  when you're putting away vegetables in  your fridge organize it in a first in  first that way meaning what you bought  most recently put it on the bottom and  if you have older product from the top  so you use a purse before it goes bad  the third thing you can do is what I  call the sniff test and so that means  that you're worried at the food's going  bad don't necessarily look at the date  but open it up and sniffing yourself  then the smells funky toss it but if it  smells perfectly good it's probably safe  to eat and you can go ahead and rent  that throw it away  [Music]